ある生徒が授業と授業の間の休み時間に1
冊の漫画ありました
おそらく自分が買ってきたものでしょう
そこに先生がやってきて
おいお前なに充てるだとちょっと注意気味
に声をかけていました
その後ろの方の席で僕は家から持ってきた
方ように行ったのですが
マナーを追ってきた彼とは違い僕のことに
関しては先生は何も注意していませんでし
た
その時は別に当然だろうとすら思ってい
ましたがもうちょい振り返って考えてみる
と何で方ロングいることに対しては何も
言われないのに万能論努力に対しては親子
言われているんだろうと思うようになり
ましたそこで学生証を調べてみることにし
ました
そこには正式で僕が出来ました
学園に持ち込める品目については学業部
活動に必要なものとする
例えばマンガン雑誌類
ゲームリー
化粧品は禁止することがあります
これに乗ってれば漫画を学校に持っている
ことに関しては怒られても仕方のないこと
かもしれません
この花ショットをして私は別に漫画を学校
にも読めるように法則を改正すべきだと声
をあげる気はないんですが気づいたことと
して
マンドは日本の文化として怒るべきものの
発想に品に比べて下に見られているという
ことです
例えば
学校の授業などでマンガ本を使うことは
ままありますがガンマンがを使うことは
なかなかありません
例えば
万能ばかり音量で勉強しなさいって言わ
れる事はありますが本ばかり読んでないで
勉強しなさい
言われることはなかなかないでしょう
本当
文化や教養ではなくサブ仮屋園ための一つ
とした認識してされてないということです
このような声になっているいうをいくつか
考えてみましょう
一つにはマンガはそもそもほど向けに作ら
れたという歴史があることです
今私たちがよく知ってるようなまんだと
いう形態は1960年代以降に立ち作られ
たものですが
昭和中期
にはマンダ差しというものが多く発行され
てい
日本の子どもたちに漫画を習慣的に読むと
いう
ことが根付い tt それは大衆娯楽とし
て成長してきました
それに比べ本や小説は明治大正の時代
まぁそいわゆる版がより前の時代に形作ら
れて
大人向けに文学として位置づけられてい
ました
そのためいまだに漫画はどうしてこれを
向けるんでしょと思っている方もいるかも
しれません
私に言わせれば
本田って
ノーベル文学賞に値するものから
子供向けの自動車まで幅広くあれじゃない
かと思いますけどもそれはともかくとして
82つ目に考えられる理由として漫画には
時とは過激な場面が現れることです
血が出たり
暴力を振られるシーンがあったり悲惨な
光景書を伝えてありがとうですねねぇ
このような言葉は多分映画をどのような
コンテンツでも多くあると思うんですけど
も映画にはしっかりとした年齢制限が設け
られています今日者によってそれに比べて
漫画は子供たちへのての入りやすさが全然
違います例えば
顔と思えば小学生でもコンビニ行って声援
漫画を買うことができます
少年まんだと青年バンガーの描写の
レギュレーションの違いはかなりあるので
それを子供が読んでところを見た親は心配
に思うかもしれません
加えて本に比べて表紙が具体的にもなり
ますしやすいということもあって子供たち
も買いやすいです
そのためマンダ和風道徳的だと思われて
いる命があるかもしれません
このような留学としても私は日本人が
もっと
漫画を文化として認識して扱ってくれると
思います
そうも理由の一つとしてマンガが常に一大
産業となっていることがあります
2019年のコミックス販売額は電子書籍
も含めると5500億円地区になります
出版業界全体で
1兆6000億円くらいなので約3割以上
のも
もの漫画の売り上げが占めることにもなり
ます
加えて昨今の人気漫画決め角やレバー
進撃の巨人
東京文字リベンジャーズなどの社会認知度
やメディアでの広がり方を見ても漫画は
すでに日本に根付いた文化経済的にですが
といって言い切っても良い気はします
さらにこの勢いは海外にも広がっています
主に多くの
人気漫画が
翻訳されていることもあり海外で海外の人
たちが日本に興味を持ったきっかけとして
アニメマンガゲームが一段というデータが
あります
海外での日本の漫画市場規模は約
1000億円と言われていますがマンガを
原作とした
映画や何でも含めるとスターに大きくなり
そうですこのように海外に影響力のある
コンテンツを伸ばしていくことこそが日本
の発展にもつながると思うで日本人日本人
全体が発信していく必要性があると思い
ます
3つ目にばんだり備わっているのは
娯楽要素だけではないという意見です
1確かに一つのエンタメウェア対州馬とし
て終わってしまう作品はない作品もあり
ますが何歳から作品には
自身の知識を深めてくれてまた新たな視点
から物事を見ることを助けに来るような
ものがいくつかあります
そんな先にを今回はいくつか紹介したいと
思います
一つ目は火の鳥です
ご存知の方もたくさんいると思いますけど
も
鉄公孫進数くれた名作です
a の命をボスと呼ばれる平取があらゆる
時代に登場して登場人物たちと関わってき
ます
その登場人物たちは
まあ物語においてストーリーにおいて人は
なぜ生きるのか
なるため級のかということという問題を
突きつけられています
仏教の輪廻転生から
彼は技術の進歩にまで幅広く
取り扱っており命についてあらゆる方面
から考えさせられます二つ目に紹介するの
は有害都市です
先ほどのレギュレーションの話と少し
変わりますが
創作物に対する
表現が過度に規制された日本社会を
リアリティのある描写と設定によって描い
ています
もし自分たちは各ような創作物
がでも
ゲームでも
漫画でも小説でもいいですがそれが政府に
よって規制されたら
もしそうなってしまったらという恐ろしと
漫画によって感じることができますこの
ように文字だけでは伝えが伝わらない伝え
られないような
感情や価値観
出来事などをうまく表現できるのがマンド
の良いところです
学ぶといるよりは流れや価値観を感じ
られるというところが大きいかなと思って
います
さらにこのような
このような中では価値観を感じられると
いった点灯
面白いストーリーが加われば読者は
読み手は
教養とエンタメの両方を手に入れることが
できます
ここまで少し本に対して否定的なことをを
言っていたように聞こえたかもしれません
が私は別に本が気合というわけでありませ
ん小説とどう読むのも大好きです
ただここで訴えたいのは
媒体で判断してほしくないということです
漫画だからな偉大なんでしょ今だからこう
なんだというような一方のどれだけに立っ
た発言をなるべく空気会でほしいなという
ふうに思っている
感じです
さて話は少しありますが
昨今日本全体で読書習慣が増えていきます
何の話をしてるんだと思われるかもしれ
ませんが
まあ何故こうなっているかといいますと
ゲームや youtube sns など
に時間を割く人の数が多くなっているから
ですね
このこと自体を別に否定したりはしません
が
成績と読書量が直結し制度を知っています
か
小規模
いわゆる本を読むことで鍛えられる国語力
だけではなく
多くの評価においてい
本を読めば読むほど政治がは上がるという
ことが成績で研究で証明されています
他にも想像力や
今日完成
ストレス解消法がどう食べると言われて
いるのでぜひ多くの人特に学生に私は本を
もっと読んで欲しいなと思っています
しかし先ほど言ったような昨今の
まあ本をあまり読まないというような現状
を見ると
方を選んだ方がいいを読みなさい嫁様と
いってもなかなか
応用ではくれないでしょう
そこでバンドを読むといったところから
もっと始めていってほしいなと思います
多くの学校は私たちの学校と同じように
版がを読むというのが禁止されているかも
しれません
しかし漫画は他の媒体に比べてはるかに話
を理解しやすいという点がポイントです
絵とストーリーと文章が理解しやすいよう
に呼びやすいように構成されていますから
ね
そのようなこともあってもっと
まんがぁもっと板東を読むことによって
読書週間につなげていってほしいなと思っ
ています
ぜひ
学校の授業や図書室などに漫画負うことを
個人の願望も含めてお願いしたいです
このように
メリット r 側面にも目を向けて
曼荼羅良いところ目を受けてほんとマン
ガーがもっと皆さんの生活にとってこの
ようなって言ったら嬉しいですご清聴
ありがとうございました